[Música]
en primera plana
carlos cerrados
[Música]
bienvenidos en primera plana un programa
de radio francia internacional y de
france 24 esta semana ponemos el foco en
el fin del curso político a quien
francia ha marcado por el fin de unas
elecciones regionales y la antesala de
unas presidenciales que se celebrarán en
10 meses para ello me acompañan en este
estudio
olivier urrutia politólogo profesor en
management y estrategias de influencia
bienvenido a libia hola buenos días y
gracias a su débil en jefa del servicio
político del huffington post' bienvenida
astrid gracias y rafael plus periodista
político en el diario la opinión
bienvenido a rafael gracias buenos días
comienza la carrera presidencial en
francia hoy en primera plana
[Música]
el presidente manuel macro ni la
ultraderechista marine lepén favoritos
para enfrentarse entre sí de nuevo por
la presidencia de francia el año que
viene acaban de llevarse una gran
derrota en las elecciones regionales que
ha celebrado el país y que ha demostrado
que los partidos tradicionales los
conservadores y los socialistas tienen
más implante para conservar el poder
hegemónico regional un resultado del que
se pueden hacer mil lecturas empezando
por la abstención dos de cada tres
franceses decidieron no ir a votar a tan
sólo diez meses de las presidenciales
hoy nos preguntamos cómo acaba este
curso político en francia y si el factor
kobe y la salida de la crisis sanitaria
van a influir en la próxima carrera
electoral por el elíseo antes de ello
repasemos algunas portadas que nos deja
la prensa el diario l'humanité pone el
acento en la abstención de las
regionales 65% la inquietante
banalización dice el diario le figaro lo
hace con los perdedores de la cita macro
en lepe en la doble sanción para
liberación suspenso para el
reagrupamiento nacional del epen dice el
rotativo que la formación del epen sale
debilitada de la cita quizá no tanto por
el resultado sino más bien por lo que
los sondeos vaticinaban
por cierto también se equivocaron bueno
las elecciones regionales suponen
llamarlo de esta forma de todas las
lecturas que podemos trazar olivier un
revulsivo para los partidos
tradicionales para los viejos partidos
tradicionales los conservadores y los
socialistas esos a los que vino macrón a
suplantar un para mí no porque se ha
visto que han conservado más o menos en
la raíz
territorial local que ya tenían es decir
que han conservado más o menos sus bases
a nivel local y me parece un poco poco
extrapolable los resultados como también
el nivel de abstención a nivel de
elecciones locales
a la presidencial de 2022 entonces si
hacemos una lectura limitada a lo que
pasó a nivel local territorial yo no veo
mucha diferencia con lo que había antes
astrid
resultados que no son extrapolables hay
que tener mucho cuidado porque a la hora
de ver desde fuera nos podemos pensar
que estas regionales pueden ser un
espejo de lo que va a pasar en 10 meses
y ahora mejor nada que ver no si hay
muchos partidos por ejemplo a la
izquierda piensan que es para ello es
una buena noticia porque por ejemplo el
partido socialista que ganó sus cinco
regiones pensadora que tienen la
posibilidad para la presidencial
mientras que no no es lo mismo
las presidenciales no son las regionales
las personas acá en francia no votan por
lo mismo
este el domingo en durante la segunda
vuelta de las elecciones regionales
votaron para el gobierno regional para
los deseos para los transportes no para
el gobernar el país no es no tiene nada
que ver y además la abstención con 66%
de las de la populación que no va a
votar y en los jóvenes es peor
tipo 80 versión de los jóvenes no van a
votar esto es muy preocupado y no tiene
nada que ver con la presidencial porque
podemos pensar que la gente va a adoptar
mucho más para la presidencia rafael me
haga extrapolable este resultado con lo
que va a pasar en 10 meses
no es difícil extrapolar porque claro
estamos ahí tratando de analizar el el
cuarto en una cuarta parte del
electorado lo que es muy poco y bastaría
con pues un punto dos cinco o diez
puntos de inflexión para que cambiara
todo pero también lo que decía astrid es
que como es el último discutido en la
última lección antes de la presidencial
es difícil no intentar largar
conclusiones por parte de los partidos
ni muchos partidos
específicamente los de la izquierda
intentaron montar diferentes estrategias
y ahora analizando están intentando ver
cuáles funcionaron cuáles no y las
configuraciones no alianzas con este
partido tres partidos dos partidos
cuatro partidos pero bueno es también
una señal de debilidad porque ese es
difícil sacar conclusiones pero es lo
que tenemos no tenemos más materia
electoral para analizar y preparar la
elección presidencial entonces estamos
un poco en este esté en esa complicación
comentemos lo que ya hay un alto una
alta tasa de abstención de más del
centro de 65 66% en estos comicios
regionales a qué se debe esta
desafección olivia habría que
preguntarle a la gente a ver
yo creo que se debe a muchas cosas se
debe lo hablábamos antes
yo creo que se debe primero al hecho de
que para mucha gente las regionales no
significan nada no suponen un cambio
profundo a nivel a nivel de su cotidiano
entonces la gente a quien francia se
espera mucho más algo de la de las
presidenciales de las regionales además
estamos en un país bastante hakobyan
bastante centralista y en un país además
con un régimen presidencialista
importante entonces lo que realmente
vertebra estructura la vida política en
francia es la presidencial además yo
creo que ha habido alguien no estamos de
acuerdo pero yo creo que ha habido
muchas elecciones últimamente
recordemos las municipales del año
pasado donde hubo la seguro además de
una gran victoria
del partido ecologista son estas
ciudades del país
a veces un problema no de lectura de
inteligibilidad es decir de qué es
realmente que son exactamente los las
elecciones regionales y para acabar hay
que decirlo muchos candidatos yo ahí lo
digo también es culpa de los candidatos
muchos no sabían tampoco mucho lo que
eran las regionales porque muchos se
confundían entre política nacional y
política regional tenían programas de
política nacional aplica una política
regional que no tiene nada que ver y que
es imposible llevar a cabo por favor
agradecemos por parte cómo quedan las
formaciones les parece empecemos por los
que han salido derrotados la república
en marcha del presidente macro ni la
ultraderecha de marín lepe en el partido
de macrón uno de los grandes perdedores
de la cita demuestra que no tiene sobre
todo implante regional que la república
en marcha era digamos un artefacto para
llegar al elíseo no más 30 y exacto ya
además de mañana con no le importan
mucho esas elecciones o es lo que dice
él porque es una paradoja porque margina
ven y emanuel manu que son los dos
lilita favoritos para las elecciones
presidenciales
y si fracasaron en esas regionales
marine le pen no consiguió ninguna
región y en el mejor tampoco y eso es lo
que decíamos es es decir que la gente no
vota para las las elecciones
presidenciales como en las regionales de
penas pero va a conseguir una región
para la ultraderecha se hablaba mucho
del alpes provenza costa azul finalmente
no ha sido así
sobre todo aspiraba a conseguirla para
que fuera un trampolín una especie de
escaparate de cara al año que viene
los sondeos así lo vaticinaban y
finalmente se trata de una decepción
histórica para la ultraderecha rafael
pues decepción no sé si histórica pero
decepción porque estuvieron en la región
estaba al alcance no sólo según los
sondeos que bueno se equivocaron sobre
todo en otras regiones equivocaciones
pero en el sureste de la región sureste
al final quedamos en un 53 para la
izquierda derecha un 47
pero el resultado el resultado perdón
que sacó el candidato de la ultraderecha
en el sureste en la primera vuelta daba
mucha posibilidad había una ventana y
había era la única región en la que si
era posible entonces que no consiguiera
el partido una región una sola región
para sentarse a sentarse perdón como un
partido
que puede gestionar el gestor que lo
cual es siempre un objetivo del partido
que siempre quiere imponerse no como
simplemente un partido de oposición
siendo un partido que puede gobernar
municipios regiones y claro un escalón
más y para llegar hasta el elíseo es una
decepción importante porque la segunda
vuelta pues muy clara la derecha gana de
manera bastante fácil con el apoyo de la
izquierda no sabemos muy bien hasta qué
grado pero con el apoyo de la izquierda
entonces ese sueño del epen de final
al final derrotar a la famosa la famosa
todos contra el pp llámese como se llame
pero vemos que no consigue pararlo al
final siempre termina en la misma pared
de su frente y podemos decir que en esta
ocasión ha sido la derecha clásica la
que ha parado los pies al epp en sí
la abstención los partidos los partidos
el partido los republicanos el partido
de derecha clásico pero yo estoy de
acuerdo para mí es mucho peor resultado
para el partido del hotel que para macri
porque bueno yo creo que cuando makoun
dice que en realidad no hay que hacer un
drama
al final él se esperaba influir o
fastidiar la la realidad fastidiar un
poco para incordiar a dzeko
el que es su propia marca
él ya ha demostrado que podría ser
eligió presidente de francia y gobernar
y formar también un gobierno magín lópez
ahí ella tenía el reto de demostrar que
podía justamente pues gestionar
efectivamente formar partido gobierno y
no lo demuestra es decir que sigue
siendo incapaz de hacerlo entonces
siempre queda la duda en el electorado
de si sería capaz como presidenta pues
formar mayoría y gobierno entonces para
mí es mucho peor para ella que para qué
para más y es buena señal para los
republicanos porque tienen a tres
candidatos potenciales rivales de makoun
y si consiguen y ahí es el reto si
consiguen ponerse de acuerdo entre ellos
para que salga un candidato con el apoyo
del partido y de la de la base electoral
sí que podrían acordar
los vencedores regionales a ver bertram
valérie pécresse solo gambo kiev como
ven por esta carrera la nominación de la
derecha clásica aquí ven con más
posibilidades a streep no saben todavía
y para mí va a ser muy difícil para
ellos encontrar el candidato porque
ahora tienen tres candidatos como como
lo he dicho y es en un lado está muy
bien para ellos porque podríamos pensar
que estaban muriendo porque mcqueen ganó
hace 54 años y el partido conservador de
irán muy bien en dificultades pero ahora
tienen tienen mucho mucho más no te
entienden tres candidatos y es mucho
porque los tres quieren ir que viene
desde bruselas tal vez
y ayer a la presidencial y además desde
allí viajó en el norte y varias fechas
en parís no están más en el partido
aunque ya están muy están con proximidad
pero con su vida de las plataformas y
como informaron en su momento también
vamos a decirnos una breve pausa y
enseguida volvemos para seguir
analizando la carrera por el icio de
2022 y cómo acaba sobre todo este curso
político aquí en francia hasta ahora